what's up guys nashville here joined
alongside austin matthews from the
toronto maple leafs it is officially
movember and you've got the best stash
in the league give us a rundown of some
of the fundraising stuff you're doing
this month
i don't know if it's the best dash in
the league but it's uh it's definitely
pretty greasy but
uh yeah i teamed up with movember you
know to raise money and awareness for
men's health so we got a lot going on
i've been wearing some special skates uh
special sticks
and uh if you go to my page and uh make
a donation of 34 or more you uh get a
chance to uh possibly win a assigned
stick game used by uh by myself so i
heard there's also a little bit of a
wager on the line if you reach your goal
of 134 000
you are going to remove the stash is
that true that is true i'm going to
shave it off and uh i'm a little bit
nervous because i don't know uh
it's been a while since i haven't had
this uh sitting above my uh
so i'm a little bit nervous about what
it's going to look like with it off but
it's all for a good cause so i'm all for
it when is the first time that you
rocked the stash and what was your
reasoning behind it a couple summers ago
my family and i went down to mexico for
a little vacation and i was just getting
ready and i was uh like you know what
i'm just i'm gonna shave and i'm gonna
leave the the muzzy up top and just kind
of roll with it down in mexico maybe see
if i can blend in a little bit better
with my heritage and
uh so i did that and uh my mom liked it
um she was probably the only one that
liked it and so i don't know i just kind
of kept it rolling for a bit and it's
kind of just become a part of me
when you shave this thing off i mean is
it going to affect your play at all is
it going to affect how confident you are
going into a game like what's that going
to be like yeah i don't know to be
honest with you it's like uh
i don't know it's like if i shave it off
i lose all my all my power i i hope
that's not the case and i hope it grows
back quick
like i said i mean it's been a long time
since i i haven't had a little bit of
facial hair above my lips so i don't
know what the time frame would be like
if i shaved it off how long it takes to
grow back or whatever but
i sure hope i don't lose uh
you know any part of me that uh you know
maybe the muzzy helps with you know the
youth the kids that are watching this
video that maybe think to themselves
i want to be like austin matthews i want
to grow the stash do you recommend that
they do it uh i highly recommend it yeah
um it might not look too good right away
but
once you get a little bit older uh you
kind of start to fill out into your body
and it starts to get a little bit
thicker and it don't look too uh
it doesn't look as greasy but i still
got a ways to go probably i want you to
name the top three toronto maple leafs
players in terms of their facial hair
not including yourself give us the give
us the rundown uh jake mason he's got
the nice beard it's kind of the same
thing like if he didn't have that beard
i i don't know if i
he just wouldn't look right you know
like it just didn't look the same who
else
uh soup soup's got a nice beard nobody
really goes muzzy maybe willy willy
doesn't have occasional uh the
occasional muzzy but he's blonde so it
kind of blends in a little bit a couple
months ago he uh he shaved his beard and
he kept the muzzy and he dyed it with
some chest for men which uh
he took a page out of my book and uh it
looked pretty nice do you dye yours at
all i do every once in a while like in
the summer when i'm just messing around
and uh i want to add a little thickness
to it i just go
to my local cvs and uh i just buy a
little adjust for men and uh
away we go i was wondering what the
secret was i think i might need to give
that a try cause i got a little blonde
here so maybe that would help me out
yeah anything helps
we're gonna bring up on screen a couple
guys from around the league i want you
to rate their stash out of 10
and say if theirs is better or worse
than yours okay
all right
oh
jeez that's
he's got the what the munch shops or
whatever the uh
i don't know out of ten i'd give it like
a six
um
yeah i know him pretty well he's pretty
greasy in general so i'd have to give
him a six i'd take mine over his though
for sure take a look at this greasy one
yeah
that's
that's commitment right there
that's commitment having to walk around
with that
yeah i can't uh i can't grow that that's
for sure but i like the uh little trin
strap looks nice i'd give it an 8 out of
10 just because the commitment to that
is not easy near and dear to your heart
we got jumbo joe yeah he's 10 out of 10.
10 out of 10 human 10 out of 10 facial
hair
um that beard is incredible and i was
talking the other day actually i think
it's even bigger than it is in that
picture and i just don't know how i
don't know how you can handle it dude i
don't know how he's playing hockey in
that thing for sure like it's adding
some weight you get sweat in there it's
adding some weight as you play it like
that's unreal your food in there like uh
anything you know like anything will pop
in there it's like uh it's like when you
look in your couch for the first time in
10 months and you just find quarters and
crumbs and nickels and whatever you
drops out of your pocket you just got
everything going on in there i think
this is actually the fairest comparison
that we can have to yours it is my boy
zach barinsky take a look at the stash
it's gotta be close it's gotta be close
what do you think it's close um it would
pair well if he had his mullet going on
too if he had the mullet with the stash
that'd be an 11 out of ten and i think
he would take the cake for sure but uh
without the mullet it's still it's still
pretty nice i'll give them like a 9 out
of 10. austin you want to give us one
more plug of your fundraising efforts
that you got going on this month yes sir
so uh you can go to my instagram page i
believe i got it up on twitter as well
uh you can donate
to my movember campaign and like i said
if you donate 34 more dollars you can
get a chance to win a signed game you
stick you know let's keep plugging away
here at this uh this fundraising thing
it's been a lot of fun
beauty man we appreciate you hopping on
we look forward to seeing you without
the staff and best of luck the rest of
this year man thanks nasher